you work for Pfizer my question for you
is why is Pfizer want to hide from the
public
the fact that they're mutating the covet
viruses I'm literally a liar I was
trying to impress a person on a date
this is why I think of James O'Keefe as
the political Chris Hanson because what
happens Chris Hanson walks in and you've
got the weird sex guys standing over in
the corner and he's got you know his
movies and popcorn or whatever and he
said why don't you have a seat over here
and what's the first thing out of the
guy's mouth every time says I wasn't
going to do anything I was just lying in
the transcripts I was just lying about
every it was all dishonest this guy is
giving the exact same answer and this
guy is presenting himself as a predator
not as a sexual predator driving to some
person's house but as as a public
Predator as someone attempting to
deceive the public on a very very
important dangerous issue from one of
the most powerful corporations in the
world